here's the story from the postmodial
breaking Fox News promotes glory holes
child sterilization to employees leaked
documents revealed Matt Walsh revealed
the fox Corporation parent company of
Fox News is encouraging employees to
celebrate pride month in all things
lgbtqia plus come on I at a certain
point I can't keep reading all these
letters now I mean that seriously maybe
just we say like the pride Community or
something by giving money to groups that
encourage sex changes for minors reading
books by trans activists including books
about children changing changing gender
gay erotica and sharing children's books
about gender transition with their with
their children and to attend activist
Pride events so this is the thread from
Matt Walsh she says we've obtained
internal documents from Fox News
employees foxcorp is celebrating Pride
by encouraging employees to read about
glory holes supporting a group that
gives sterilizing hormones to homeless
Youth and deployed woke AI to monitor
everyone
this is a big long thread but uh I will
just say this uh first and foremost I
can confirm this now I can't confirm
each and every uh intricate detail what
I can confirm is I have I have spoken
with Fox employees who have told me
exactly this
and I do believe personally that what
was going on at Fox was well known in
the media space among anyone who is
considered to be libertarian
conservative in this in this space not
every single libertarian but mostly the
anti-woke anti-leftist or whatever if
there's a conservative personality I
think most of them knew this was going
on at Fox
and I think people just didn't want to
call out Fox because then they would not
be invited onto Fox to speak they
wouldn't get the air time now in the
past couple of months there have been
some goings on where we became privitist
information and the main reason we have
not really brought anything up as one we
didn't get leak documents or anything
like that we just had testimony from
employees and we were asked to wait as a
story was being prepared and sure enough
bang the story just came out Matt Walsh
dropping the documents this is actually
uh
unsurprising
but I think what uh what y'all need to
realize is that Fox News is
what can I call it a hoax well this is
I've said this before right CNN tells
you what you're supposed to believe and
then Fox tells you what you're allowed
to believe if you're someone who
genuinely can't stomach the nonsense
that they're pushing over at CNN you can
go over to Fox and they'll tell you
what's within the confines of socially
acceptable conservatism the whole goal
I'm not saying it's an Express or
intentional goal of the people at the
Fox network but it just happens to work
out this way that they give you a much
more brand safe version of the ideology
in a kind of Kohl's people this is part
of why Tucker Carlson was so dangerous
to their status quo because he was
Shifting the Paradigm in an
anti-establishment and a direction that
was further to the right and so he was
he was saying things that previously
conservatives uh would have been
considered nut jobs for saying because
he was actually offering up a narrative
counter to what the establishment was
saying without simply making the
argument that I don't like what CNN
saying um I don't like what Joe Biden is
doing but without actually promoting a
substantive counter ideology if that
makes sense
and so we had a whole conversation about
this when he was forced out but my point
is fox has always kind of been there to
be uh CNN light in a sense right that's
why no one cares about Hannity right I
mean like people watch him obviously but
when it came to the Dominion lawsuit
Tucker Carlson's the one that gets the
boot Tucker Carlson is the one that is
getting silenced the other personalities
they have are acceptable mainstream uh
harmless conservative values yeah like
the establishment isn't that horrified
if you talk about cutting top marginal
tax rates by five percent or you know
whatever your policy is being proposed
by The Establishment Republicans and
cutting tax rates is not a bad thing to
do I'm in favor of that but you're not
going to get in as much trouble for
saying that as you are going to for
pointing out the transgender and lgbtq
agenda or the fact that January 6th was
almost certainly a Fed selection and
there was Federal involvement the kinds
of things Tucker was saying which got
him pushed off of the network now uh I
wonder why it is
and we want to take a shot at it uh how
come we're only learning about it now
I mean people like Fox News have been
been working for a long time this is not
new stuff they're doing they've been
doing it for some time so how come only
now are we learning about it well I
think a lot of people who work at the
Fox network are not conservative right
and so they wouldn't feel a need to blow
the whistle on this
I mean this is not just not conservative
yeah no I hear you but far left sexual
agreed but that's what the left has been
completely taken over by right I mean
these are these are people who the
people who work at foxes are people who
work in media who have a New York but
you know what I'm not saying that's
everyone at Fox but maybe the argument
that they're default liberals who don't
pay attention and don't care but if
that's the case then these people
sitting by well this is the kind of
stuff that gets pushed to them by Fox I
mean at the very least they could come
and be like not Fox ain't conservative I
think this could also be a case where
the HR department is a different than
than the the the rest of the employees
right I mean I've worked a lot of
Corporations where the HR department is
sending out communiques and memos that
the employees are like what is this and
it's like ad Steve from HR and you just
throw it away I'm not saying that what's
happening is good
um but HR is is one of the first places
that that the left has infiltrated
that's true but it's a little bit more
than that Matt Walsh continues says not
all Fox employees are happy with this
propaganda that might be why last year
Fox experimented with a solution to
monitor employees commitment to Dei it's
an AI platform called escalera which
tracks employees commitment to The Cult
of Dei Fox leadership told employees to
sign up for escalera so that the AI
could help them engage in activities
that will deepen their understanding of
identity and explore more nuanced D and
I Concepts I I just feels like aliens
took over you know like there's like
aliens being like put the brain slug in
your brain and you're like I don't know
if I want to do that
you know what I mean yeah and it's even
creepier than that right I I won't get
into too much detail but we all know
that they're focusing on a different
organ and they're also focusing on
children yeah I think this is
ride month I will say it's sort of the
most memorable at least in my memory uh
and I think part of it is uh to your
question of why why are these documents
being released now I think people are
ready to start this debate in a way they
weren't in years past I think for so
long especially when the conversation
was about uh gay marriage which it was
increasingly popular people were uh more
willing to have conversations about LGBT
well LGB issues in the last place and
then when the tea was added and it got
it sort of became the most dominant
letter people became more resistant and
I think we're really seeing that play
out now uh and I I will honestly give
Dylan Mulvaney credit for this I mean
Dill Mulvaney and Bud Light really
kicked off a national debate over what
we are okay with talking about and what
we are okay with our companies it could
be the the pride month to end all Pride
months which would be great it'd be
beautiful right this is the last one the
last one and and look how many
corporations that uh June 1 they changed
their avatars to the rainbow and June 2
it was gone they were like like all
right you got your day which is kind of
what you do on St Patrick's Day and what
you do on you know you get your little
one day in the Sun and and if this is
the pride month to end all Pride months
I think a lot of people would be
absolutely thrilled with that I think
about what I think people thrilled I
mean I I can't I I've said this before
on the show but I can't imagine if you
were part of this community and suddenly
your entire identity is co-opted by this
Fringe movement that would just be
terrible this would be the worst and it
is I'm not surprised that Omega
corporation like Fox is is bowing down
to Dei I mean I kind of don't trust
anyone and expect that they all do this
I think it's hard for the American
public because uh in many ways there's
no alternative to Fox so to feel this
level of betrayal is is upsetting we we
will get into this story in a little bit
later but I will also mention that there
was a tweet from an organization called
Music Fest in I think it's Bethlehem
Pennsylvania and they were advertising a
an all ages drag show we I put out a
tweet about it saying like what's this
all about Yingling they deleted the
Tweet oh boy the the you know internally
in The Newsroom they were like wow uh
you know I won't say the reporter's name
but they're like man it's been it's been
a rough month it's been a rough pride
month yeah like yeah maybe this is the
end of pride month because you you had
what major league baseball got rid of
their their pride logo within a day or
two Xbox did the same thing you got
Starbucks reeling from it uh or uh you
know say take this stuff down not
denying it you've got Target losing
market share Bud Light is now they've
been knocked down from the top spot I
gotta tell you if you've got a marketing
guy if you've got a finance guy and
they're walking into their executive
boardrooms and they're going look we got
to get our ESG score up this guy's
probably going ESG you're gonna lose 30
of your market cap if you do this and
they're gonna be like yeah but we won't
get financing if we don't be like what
what do you need financing for if you
have no customers and they're like okay
Washington posted a funny article today
about how uh
that the Bud Light deal was not
necessarily about Dylan Mulvaney but
because there's a movement towards craft
breweries anyway
and I'm good like wait wait uh
but uh the ultimate Spin Doctors at the
Washington Post they're probably off on
this
course are skyrocketing yeah yeah it
said domestic beer is stagnating it's
like oh that's why Miller and Coors are
up 20 some odd percent yeah this is
these are craft breweries
yes very small small little scrappy
startup Miller no one's buying it
anymore no you know that I I really do
think we're at a point where most people
know the media is lying I gotta tell you
man I'm I'm fairly optimistic because
there are a lot of people I know
who are they consider themselves to be
moderate but for the longest time maybe
like a year ago or pre-covered really
but like during covet and slightly and
like into covert maybe a year ago they'd
be saying stuff like that it's not true
you guys are crazy now they're going
really yeah when I say things now
they're just like
we've seen enough like at a certain
point you just can't keep lying about
everything and expect people to believe
you go people don't pay attention
they'll hear it and they'll say that's
probably true but at a certain point
they're like I don't know man let me
check and then they do it starts slowly
with some people and then it starts
ramping up the more people that speak
out the more people are willing to speak
out and I think ultimately what it comes
down to is you know we hear that story
from Brandon strzok you got have you
heard a story before the walk away story
that uh he thought Donald Trump was
mocking a disabled reporter and so when
someone challenged him he was like okay
I'll debunk this and then he looks it up
and sure enough Trump was not and that
he said it physically hurt when he was
watching it like he didn't know what to
do
someone like that then comes out and
people say ah he's far right he's
grifting that works for a little while
but eventually you're in the city you're
in Miami you're in New York who knows
where right and you you have a party and
then everyone is basically in line with
the corporate establishment narrative
except for like one or two people and
then someone says something in past and
it's not true and then one person
finally stands up and now I looked that
up that's not true check watch I'll show
you and they're like wait what really
eventually people who are looked up to
or maybe have higher Social Status start
rejecting it which creates a wave of
more and more people stepping out
rejecting it then you get that
inflection point Bud Light now everyone
can see that woke is shriveling and
failing and now I'm hearing stories of
non-political channels and like
YouTubers and influencers for no reason
just being like Oh I'm not woke by the
way like I'm not I'm gonna do any of
that yeah because they're worried about
not being popular and there are some
watershed moments that led to that I
mean the Dylan Mulvaney I agree with 100
was was in this movement
um covid I think it was when Joe Rogan
said that CNN when they said on CNN that
Joe Rogan was taken horse dewormer and
that's when Joe Rogan was like are you
kidding me like like this and he it was
such a viral moment that everyone
realized oh wow CNN just lies about
these things and and so yeah that's when
the people in the crowd are starting to
realize they're not telling us all the
truth here are they and the more this
happens the better it is for society but
it's why platforms like this are
important that's why Joe Rogan's
important it's my alternative media is
important lying about Joe Rogan is a
bold move yeah he could he I mean he has
such a massive platform he can so easily
disprove it and there were other ways
that the media be clowned themselves
through the covid pandemic I think
I I was hoping to get away with just
throwing that one out
when
the BLM riots were happening when CNN
published that article and a number of
other outlets did as well publicizing
the fact that over a thousand health
professionals signed a letter saying
that you shouldn't shut down these
protests because of covid-19 after
they'd spent months telling you that you
can't go to church that you can't go to
work that you can't see dying relatives
at the hospital that you can't go to
funerals for loved ones that is when a
lot of people woke up and said oh it was
all nonsense it was all having my
fingers over here I'm seeing it you
disagree I'm waiting for Sheamus to
complete his point so I can jump in but
I'm waving frantically he's been waiting
this whole time they did not just say
don't stop BLM protests they actually
said BLM protest stopped the spread of
coven
even better it's amazing they actually
let me just I'll try and follow this
pull this one up why are you pulling it
up you know it was the example of how
many people were losing loved ones and
then John Lewis there we go like John
Lewis gonna have you here we go yeah
look at this right June 30th 2020 black
lives matter protests may have slowed
overall spread of coronavirus in Denver
and other city's new study fines amazing
and at a certain point someone just
looks at and goes on there a minute you
can't just say it's a new study when
you're like my opinions
myself and I said it was fine imagine
being poor John in Gold like when you
had a when you were just or like like
like pathetic John Ingle like when you
had to write that and and just imagine
had to staring yourself from the mirror
and well you know or was compelled to
because he was so moved by the BLM
stopped the spread they were all they
were all vaccinated at University of
Colorado Denver Professor there was one
Professor BLM staff when I'm a kid and
I'm watching the Batman animated series
you know I have a question how does the
Joker have henchmen right that I'm
watching The Dark Knight movie and then
the Joker burns his pile of money and
he's like tell your guys they work for
me now and he's like they won't work for
a freak and I'm like why would anybody
work for this guy he's burning all the
money
and then you realize why is this guy
writing this right because some people
are just henchmen they just don't have
independent thought they stand there
with drool pulling out of their mouths
and then their boss goes hey write a
story that claims Black lives matter
protest slowed covet slowed coven I was
like okay then he just writes it it's
like the dude may as well just be an AI
at this point well actually fair point
we can probably fire all these people
and replace them with AI so no
journalists and writers are very
important
lesson writers I'm not I'm talking about
timcast.com I'm talking about the
biggest threat the biggest industry
under threat right now is the propaganda
industry AI is going to replace all
these people how do we even know this
guy's real for all we know they they
started doing AI articles over 10 years
ago so is that why they were always
threatened by the work by the term learn
to code because it quite literally was
going to replace them as journalists it
was offensive because they're all
actually an AI that does know how to
code and it's like I how dare you it was
offensive because you're only allowed to
talk to poor people that way basically
well yeah I don't know the working class
need to learn to code because the market
changes in the needs of the people shift
over time me no I just get to have this
job forever thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time